on est en direct pour les demi-finales
et la finale
de la de la looser de la looser ku
aujourd'hui extraordinaire on va suivre
Erik easy contre Wesley Sow alors
attendez il faut que je réussisse à
récupérer les caméras des joueurs
et on va je vais aller récupérer les
caméras des joueurs il y a fab qui
arrive évidemment pour suivre
ce superbe match
qui est un patient évidemment
ah ouais alors là Fab
je sais que tu en as pas dormi la nuit
de savoir qui allait se qualifier
hier soir
un second une seconde fois Carlson
carreau est-ce que finalement quelqu'un
d'autre viendrait
s'immiscer et nous empêcher de voir ce
nouveau classique ce serait dommage
ouais mais bon peut-être chaud peut-être
chaud qui qui est toujours dangereux
dans ces formats qui est un très bon
joueur qui a aussi bien sur internet
très beau joueur Internet
je suis en train de bien cadrer pour
bien les avoir
dans un Fab je vais mettre les noms des
joueurs au bon endroit et c'est ça ici
série en haut et on va pouvoir suivre
ce que tout le monde attend un Fab
savoir qui va rejoindre Carlson en
finale
et ça joue déjà ouais enfin on a rien
raté on a raté les deux premiers coups
donc espagnol classique voilà
alors c'est par magie non
dans ces demi-finale de la looser cue
exactement Fab merci à toi
toujours là
et donc c'est un anti Marshall avec A4
il a pas il a pas joué le C3 laissant
des 5 comme hier par exemple à faire
contre Magnus
désolé non je comprends
il a fait à 4 il y a ub4 qui a un coup
parmi tant d'autres et il a choisi à 5
donc à 5 l'idée c'est de pas le laisser
faire au noir pour pas rembourser le
pion B4
ça peut donner la case au four à 4
parfois et en général le calibéen va
aller en D2 et parfois arrondir vers ces
quatre
c'est très bien joué Fab
magnifique et cavalier des deux
ça développe ça développe ça développe
tranquillement
est-ce que so est favori d'après toi
normalement oui
gros favoris un peu favori
favoris
je sais pas exactement quoi non mais ni
si gros et plus qu'un peu 65 35
c'est beau déjà quand même
c'est quand même un meilleur joueur et
il a l'habitude de ces formats sur
Internet etc donc
spécialiste internet oui oui mais moi
enfin je sais pas combien saute depuis
longtemps mais il y a ici spécialiste
aussi quand même tu as deux spécialistes
du truc ça peut tu vois c'est quand même
un duel de spécialiste il reste plus que
des spécialistes en vrai
c'est un gros joueur partout n'a qu'à
aussi ça aussi plus spécialiste mais il
faut quand même spécialiste aussi
gagner l'an dernier sur internet quand
même juste derrière Carlsen un cas bon
il est toujours là
[Musique]
en fait ah il gagne tous les tournois à
un moment il s'est calmé mais un petit
coup de frein parce que bon ça gagne un
peu tout donc un moment donné bon il a
fallu quand même un peu que les autres
se mettent à niveau il devait pas être
bien
mais
sur
la mêlée carbure fort mais des fois il a
des coups de chauds
il fait magnifique joueur en réalité
souvent on moque ça poutre rit mais en
fait il est très dur à battre quoi j'ai
pas vraiment pleutre et puis ils s'en
foutent
gagner il s'en fout de perdre en fait
mais du coup en fait ça solidité est
très bien pour tous ces matchs comme ça
en gros si tu perds jamais bon bah au
pire ça je l'Armageddon bah c'est ce qui
compte maca mais je veux dire tu vas pas
tout le temps de battre en armée non
plus quoi
mais il a moins confirmé en réel que que
so évidemment puisque Soho était dans le
top mondial Maria ici il enchaîne les
grosses en rapite sur Internet
ouais ouais non mais après on verra ce
qui deviendra mais c'est un bon petit
joueur quoi c'est débarrassé de goût
cache
sympa cette idée de loser que finalement
ça rajoute un jour de compétition ça
permet de revoir éventuellement un
rematch Carlson Naka c'est quand même
une idée très novatrice très
intéressante femme
en deuxième quand même je sais pas trop
quoi penser en fait pourquoi pas
dans ce n’est pas indispensable non plus
mais c'est pour être sûr de vraiment
avoir les deux meilleurs en finale oui
mais bon
tu fais un tableau et puis si en fait tu
es quasiment sûr d'avoir tout le temps
Carl sen n'a qu'à en finale puisque
après tu es qualifié d'office si tu
allais en finale en premier donc tu dois
te repasser pour tous les autres par la
Via de calife et c'est vrai que ça te
permet de voir peut-être sur toute la
saison je sais pas enfin 12 du coup et
10 matchs un peu peut-être 7 7 8 matchs
dans l'année c'est quand même sympa
c'est les deux meilleurs tu as envie de
les voir s'affronter non mais je voulais
dire 10 entre le winner
peut-être une dizaine de fois mais c'est
sympa
c'est sympa pour être bien sûr
au moins tu es tu as les deux meilleurs
et tu vois vraiment à la fin de la
saison sera vraiment lequel des deux est
le meilleur au bout d'un moment quand
vous rentrez d'image
les autres quoi pourquoi tu me prends
pas que tu leur fais faire ce que tu es
pas bien sûr
après si tu veux regarde par du principe
que nepo il joue pas vraiment c'est
tournant à fond il s'en fout un peu
complètement
guéri c'est un son cette saison surtout
il a plus envie d'aller aux candidats je
crois que c'est vraiment son objectif
donc il s'en fout aussi car Wana ça
jamais été son truc internet
mvl il s'entendent plus ou moins enfin
il joue mais il s'entend pas de plus ou
moins à lire et ça on a vu qu'ils sont
tamponné donc en fait Carl scène Naka
des joueurs en fait des joueurs qui
s'entendent pas et qui sont forts il y a
que ça en réalité
donc forcément c'est sûr qu'après entre
un en train Naka Carlsen et un Erika
easy ou quoi
8 fois sur 10 ou 9 fois sur 10 ils vont
gagner
puis là en plus c'est double
illumination donc
après si dépôt etc prenait le truc au
sérieux je suis pas sûr qu'ils arrivent
aussi souvent en finale personnellement
si tous les meilleurs prenaient le truc
au sérieux je suis pas sûr
mais
je pense que ça pourrait ça pourrait
changer un petit peu le scénarios mais
mettant que ces joueurs là prendront un
peu le le truc
par dessus la jambe c'est c'est
compliqué quoi d'avoir des gens qui sont
capables de rivaliser contre
j'ai envie de dire ces trois joueurs
parce que saut il va aussi marquer
beaucoup de points normalement
donc tu as quand même trois joueurs qui
sont nettement au-dessus du lot et qui
devrait régner en mètre sur sur les
saisons sur la saison et les différentes
compétitions
après si un allié résa ou un mvl ou un
époque qualifié pour la finale en
réel il pourrait être plus motivé et là
il y a combien de joueurs pour la finale
là je crois qu'il y a des playoffs de
finale real puis la finale real mais je
sais pas il y a beaucoup de compétition
une autre en mais je l'avais attends je
vais regarder entre les entre les doigts
maintenant juillet je sais il y en a une
fin août début septembre je sais
alors
ouvre-nous le calendrier sur le
téléphone on est là donc 6 février
première événement le Racing master
après le second évènement c'est du 37
avril juste avant le champion du monde
événement 300 mai du 22 26 événement 4
du 10 au 14 juillet juste avant la Coupe
du monde je pense évènement 5 28 août
1er septembre alors attends je vais
regarder les je vais regarder les
grandes chaises tours en même temps
parce que c'est je j'ai l'impression
qu'il se mette un peu les mêmes dates
grande chaise tour 2023 et date du
grandes chaises tours parce qu'en fait
c'est pour c'est pour vous dire un peu
sinon suivrait en priorité cette
compétition ou le grand chef tour parce
que moi j'ai du grandes chasseur du 19
au 26 mai ah bah ça clash en plein
milieu lui c'est du 22 26 mai je pense
que ça c'est plus important quand même
que Manchester
ah ça c'est largement plus important
mais après le truc c'est que Maxime
airesa ils vont plutôt jouer le grand
chef tour donc nous on suivra quand même
plutôt Maxime et ally resa mais dans un
tournoi moins important le grand chef
tour mais après ouais ils sont moins au
top top Maxime je pense qu'il Carouge et
Magnus joueront plutôt cette compétition
il y a plus d'argent
donc attendez moi j'ai 4 4 au 16 mai
grande chaise tours toi tu as 400
mais j'ai grandieste tour
après toi tu as quoi j'ai 10 14 juillet
alors moi j'ai 3 18
tours pourront pas jouer le play-in
normalement non donc ça clash encore ok
événement 5 28 août 1er septembre donc
là c'est peut-être pendant les signes
que fil des compagnies non parce que
find a été décalé mais c'est juste après
la Coupe du Monde
événement 6 25 septembre à mettre pas la
date de fin ça doit être
37 ans parce que ça
pour éclash non 25 septembre dans sa
classe pas je pense
alors les playoffs du coup après sans
décembre du 4-12 et du 15 au 22
est-ce que les joueurs qui vont jouer
les championnats du monde de Blitz vont
jouer à fond ouais sûrement parce que
c'est le 25 après ils auront le temps de
voyageurs un peu jusque sur les premiers
événements mais pas sur les derniers
voilà donc là vous avez le commander
tous les événements donc il y a 6
tournois qualificatifs pour les playoffs
et la grande finale et donc les PF faire
un nombre de joueurs
pour jouer et c'est quand du coup la
grande finale tu as dit du bien
c'est quand même sympa j'imagine ça va
faire un peu comme l'an dernier là tu
sais un genre de toute ronde en Suisse
en système suisse en système tout tronc
de match c'est ce qu'ils avaient fait
l'an dernier je crois comme ça tu as
tout le monde qui rejoue et qui marque
des points matchs à chaque fois ok ok et
les deux grands vainqueurs ou peut-être
même tu vois tu fais des demi et je sais
plus
bien sûr non tu peux aussi avoir un
playoff avec des gens qui
genre la place 3 à 6 qui peut être en
playoff rejoindre des demi-finales pour
la place 1 2 qui rentrent un peu comme
au rugby j'ai pas lu ça les règles pour
moi voilà vous avez le calendrier sous
les yeux mais ouais évidemment c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle pour le pour le Grand
chasto
qui a pas vraiment révolutionné les
échecs contrairement à ce qui prétendait
alors ça je sais pas si ça
révolutionnera mais en tout cas il y a
quelque chose de tenter de nouveau
pas le double looser bracket quand même
qui te met très bien ouais puis double
élimination je sais pas comment
s'appelle mais qui te met extrêmement
bien
mais donc clairement on voit que
finalement il y a plusieurs circuits qui
se mettent en place donc il y a celui-là
là
et tu as la figue qui fait son truc à
trois circuits différents
et j'arrive toujours pas à comprendre et
j'ai l'impression que les joueurs en ont
de plus en plus rien à de tout
non mais c'est donc il y a de plus en
plus d'argent dans des tournois à gauche
à droite et que
l'importance
oui
j'ai l'impression que chaque joueur en
fait se donne l'importance Hikaru et
Magnus clairement c'est des trucs
Internet
après tu as d'autres joueurs un peu
comme ça iriga easy Sarine etc qui sont
aussi plus internet tu as un genre de
groupe
carwana Guiri
de championnats du monde est un genre de
groupe un peu au milieu genre les vannes
ou quoi qui cliquent un peu tout partout
et qui voit ce qui tombe en fait à trois
groupes de joueurs quoi tu as ceux qui
sont vraiment internet donc j'irai
maintenant vraiment vraiment Hikaru et
Magnus et so il y a Ikaru Magnus so
Sarry nerigasis je rajouterais Sarana
Alcantara
tu vois que
[Musique]
son vraiment sur le truc Internet
les autres joueurs tu vas avoir ouais
ceux que j'ai cité avant mvl à l'IRESA
peut-être Douda machin qui sont quand
même encore plus sur le classique pour
être champion du monde et ceux qui sont
un peu là et un peu partout
puis voici un truc se passe bien ou pas
ouais
en tout cas ça clique entre iriga easy
et SOS
est-ce que les blancs vont réussir à
prendre l'avantage on va le voir bon
pour le son nom mais
à tout moment
en gros
si on arrive à bien faire français 5 au
bon moment ça va
te reprendre assis puis on prend il est
faible on rentre voilà mais pour
l'instant bien sûr France 5 on a un
problème sur F2 donc il faudra gérer ça
faire un petit F3 probablement pour
consolider
et
après ça deviendra une sorte de menace
latente dans la position il faudra faire
avec côté noir et mvl dans lequel mvl
mvl carwana tout ce qui est guéri etc
ils sont vraiment sur sur le Montréal
quoi pour le format réel là il joue sur
Internet aussi parce que bon pourquoi
pas mais
priorité au réel mais après je dois dire
que parmi les joueurs pour être
complètement honnêtes et transforme avec
le public les joueurs qui mettent le
réel en avant pour les connaître un
petit peu en perso quoi c'est que ils
ont aussi du mal avec Internet
il pense pas forcément que tout est
toujours naturel et du coup ils arrivent
pas à jouer
en fait ils arrivent juste pas
physiquement à jouer correctement parce
qu'ils
ben voilà quoi ils arrivent pas vraiment
à croire en la
l'honnêteté des adversaires je sais pas
trop comment dire quoi ils ont toujours
un doute en tête donc ils arrivent pas
trop à cliquer
et après ceux qui réussissent à faire
abstraction de ça réussit à beaucoup
mieux jouer
mais il faut réussir à en faire
abstraction quoi
c'est pas évident c'est pas évident mais
forcément du coup il te beaucoup plus
vite il y a des variantes qui se font
moins confiance et encore une pointe il
y a encore un truc que j'ai pas vu ah
tiens tel coup en réel il aurait jamais
joué alors que ça veut rien dire en fait
peut-être que il y a pas de souci ils
arrivent pas trop en faire abstraction
Fab et ça c'est quelque chose c'est pas
facile de le combattre
oui ça touche à ta confiance en plus tu
vas jouer grand bien et tu préfères
faire un peu l'impasse quand en quelque
sorte
pour pas que ça les impacte dans les
parties réelles
je le bat bah tiens sur Internet Simba
partout après tu te mets à perdre
partout
ça veut rien dire bah c'est plus fin du
coup il t'impacte pas du tout
psychologiquement et
c'est plus facile quoi
donc il y a un peu ça aussi qui existe
et ça se comprend
c'est un peu comme si tu avais des cours
cyclistes et puis dans la saison tu as
quelques courses cyclistes sans réel
contrôle antidopage
ces mecs là non je suis plus fort que en
montagne puis là bon
et te dépose
je vais favoriser le circuit avec les
contrôles ça veut pas dire que les mecs
c'est-à-dire que tu as un problème de
confiance du coup tu te sens est-ce que
je peux le suivre est-ce que je peux pas
le sujet tu n'arriverai pas à savoir
quoi donc tu fais quoi donc tu préfères
un peu faire l'impasse et dire bon je
roule à mon rythme et puis tant pis quoi
c'est juste pour réussir à faire une
relation de nez ça veut pas du tout dire
que les mecs se taperaient sur le truc
où il y a pas de contrôle ou beaucoup
moins ça veut rien dire quand on sait
pas en fait on sait pas
mais c'est une idée qui te trotte comme
ça et qui t'empêche peut-être d'être
performant quoi
de toute façon ça se joue à le sport de
haut niveau ça se joue tellement à des
détails
un peu plus de confiance pour une
confiance déjà
et oui et puis du coup sur certains
coups un coup il fait important ou pas
ça te tue la confiance c'est l'écart est
tellement minime qu'il suffit d'un coup
sur un match en cas de parties pour que
ça tourne dans un dans un sens l'un
l'autre et si t'as pas la confiance tu
as pas la confiance hein
u
mon adversaire a une petite vessie ben
ouais ouais mais c'est enfin moi ça
m'est arrivé une fois d'aller voir un
arbitre
l'adversaire se levait à chaque coup
avec une mallette dans la main il
partait aux toilettes non mais
j'ai dit à l'arbitre je veux bien qu'il
aille aux toilettes ou quoi mais que on
vérifie sa mallette quoi
mais j'arrivais plus à jouer enfin ça me
s'il y avait rien dans sa mallette en
plus hein parce que du coup il est plus
à l'aéroport
mais oui c'est un truc qui te fait une
idée paradis et ça t'empêche de de
performer
tu peux pas savoir ce que dans la
manette en plus
disons que si lui il le fait moi je mets
un ordi dans ma mallette et puis je vais
aux chiotte et puis je vais regarder tu
vois c'est ce que je me disais moi aussi
je vais prendre une mallette et puis je
suis à tous les coups enfin genre au
bout d'un moment
d'un autre côté ça aurait été un peu
grillé si avec elle enfin quand il
réfléchit c'est pas trop discret quoi
tu vois il y a peut-être plus discret
qu'une
non mais oui
mais ça m'avait complètement j'arrivais
pas
j'arrivais pas à me concentrer en fait
ça me prenait la tête non mais j'ai
connu ça tu as connu ça c'est toi une
petite anecdote du coup on tournoi
non mais c'est une partie où en fait
un joueur
je sais pas pourquoi on me dit avant
ouais on a eu des soupçons autant
d'avant
[Musique]
j'étais pas au courant moi je l'ai
jamais soupçonné de moi-même mais bon
d'accord
voilà il y avait un tel qui pensait que
peut-être il tricher bon ok je vais à la
partie
qui fait le plot à me regarder ma partie
et là je sais pas qui c'est ce mec je ne
l'ai jamais vu en fait normalement
ça fait 30 ans que je vous ai tourné
quoi tu as déjà croisé tout le monde
c'est un inconnu notoire je sais pas
pourquoi il est là regardez ma partie
quoi va te balader je m'en fous enfin et
en fait je me dis ça c'est son complice
et c'était fini j'étais plus dans la
partie je passais mon temps à le
regarder et si je faisais des gestes et
j'ai plus joué un coup quoi j'étais
comme ça bon bah l'autre a pas eu
l'autrichies il a fait une partie de
merde on adversaire d'ailleurs mais moi
encore plus et puis ça t'empêche de
jouer hein
c'était un tournoi c'était il y a
longtemps donc il peut y avoir des
inexactitudes dans mon histoire mais
c'est un tournoi tu vois dans le centre
de la France du côté de Clermont là-bas
tu vois et tu vois il y avait des prix
par catégorie et il y a un gars comme ça
je sais pas qui est 150 1580 et
qui marche bien tu vois ça se voit qu'il
joue bien
et mon pote bon tu vois il connaissait
un peu tout le monde dans le coin et il
va à la buvette entre les parties tu
vois c'est un semi rapide il va chauffer
les gars dis-moi ce gage je le connais
il a pris la licence quelqu'un d'autre
c'est pas lui il est pas du tout 1580 si
les gens 2000-200 en fait et en fait il
vient pour raser les prix bon les mecs
au début oui bon enfin j'y vais j'ai du
bol parce que du coup le mec au début il
se rend rien bon il est là bon on verra
bien et puis le mec il va il cartonne
vraiment quoi et du coup à chaque enfin
tu vois entre chaque partie après il
retourne au début les mecs se chauffer
un peu et tout puis bon je commence à
leur payer des bières des machins
et du coup tu as 4h 5h j'ai dû les caler
ils étaient tous chauds c'est la gueule
en fait
trois quatre bières bon le con machin
on va le défoncer ce connard quoi je le
connais lui que 180 elle a volé une
licence c'est pas lui
et je sais pas si ça fait bien jouer le
joueur du coup enfin je sais pas si tout
le monde était devenu parano réussi à
jouer contre lui ou quoi pareil mais bon
bah le gars il est fini de sa catégorie
il était très heureux je fais tout le
monde et je le connais
mais
du coup de ces anecdotes pour dire que
oui ça peut être une raison pour
laquelle certains joueurs réussissent
pas performer parce qu'il réussissent
pas à s'enlever de l'esprit l'idée si on
laisse quelqu'un seul devant son
ordinateur ben vu qu'il peut tricher
qu'il y a beaucoup d'argent en jeu il le
fera et tu as des joueurs qui
réussissent à s'en à ceux qui
sont là qui réussissent à dire oui bon
tant pis il y en a qui triche il y en a
qui triche et puis je clique donc qui
réussissent vraiment à faire
à faire fi de ça et d'autres qui ont
plus de mal quoi
le mec je le défonce en réel et puis là
tout d'un coup qu'est-ce qui se passe il
vaut mieux que moi pourquoi tu vois donc
il commence à être parano et c'est ce
qui explique les femmes et ce que je
vous explique maintenant c'est que du
coup c'est un engrenage négatif et tu
arrives plus à performer quoi
une fois que tu t'es mis ça dans la tête
tu peux plus te l'enlever non
donc voilà pour pour la petite
explication
on peut pas vraiment réagir avec le chat
mais n'hésitez pas à nous poser des
questions ou nous dire si c'est clair ou
pas
ou si c'est pas clair
la partie c'est toujours mieux pour
Wesley mais bon oh c'est un peu insipide
en gros bon les noirs on visait à 5 avec
le cavalier mais ils peuvent pas
vraiment le prendre parce que le
qualifié la défense de décises donc une
sorte de statu quo dans cette partie de
l'échiquier et en fait c'est un peu les
blancs quand les clés s'ils veulent
faire quelque chose donc essayer de
faire F4 un truc allez droit un jour ou
rien il faut rien se passera rien quoi
donc voilà on va voir ce que fait ici
mais bon il est pleutre après je pense
qu'il va quand même essayer quelque
chose il est quand même obligé de gagner
une partie à un moment donné quoique
peut se dire qu'il va prendre les Noirs
à l'Armageddon non mais il est pleutre
mais quand même quand il est mieux
un souci de triche en proces League avec
l'histoire avec petrociant
alors ça ça a été intéressant quand même
comme histoire parce que du coup le
joueur n'avait pas été ban wesh a fait
un article pour dire qu'il tricher il a
été ban à posteriori non son équipe du
coup a perdu le match mais il y a jamais
eu de preuves probantes qui ont été
ses doigts lui c'est pas une grande
preuve ça
veut dire qu'il aurait été 27 50 filles
il aurait joué les mêmes parties il
aurait pas été ban le gars non non
si tu as pas de preuves tu as pas de
preuves en fait et tu as même pas accusé
et c'est même toi qui grave d'accuser
et c'est le joueur qui a été ban et
quand jobaval à la fin du coup il y a un
changement de politique c'est chaud Baba
qui a été ban est-ce que si soit avait
fait la même chose maintenant ça aurait
été ceux qui auraient été ban je je n'ai
pas la réponse évidemment mais
un truc marrant c'est dam dam prend B5
mais ouais non j'en sais rien enfin en
gros oui on se tacuse quelqu'un faut des
preuves quoi c'est quand même la moindre
des choses tu peux avoir des doutes ou
quoi ça c'est pas le problème mais
c'est à des doutes
pour toi
directement et encore moins publicment
et compagnie
mais là du coup le résultat avait été
avait été renversé soit avait perdu
cette partie on sera jamais si son
adversaire avait triché ou pas alors
il a été ban pour triche mais je vais
reparle que tout le monde peut être ban
pour triche
les doigts ou rien d'autre chose enfin
toute façon sur internet tu auras jamais
de preuves probante pour être sûr à 100%
ça n'existe pas donc
preuve oui mais c'est en réalité ça peut
exister tu peux retrouver des preuves
mais c'est dur enfin tu vois pas
toujours avoir une photo d'un mec au
chiottes quoi
mais donc ouais Wesley qui avait qui
avait accusé ce joueur en fait pour le
l'épreuve entre guillemets c'est soit en
fait on commence faire confiance au data
et en fait si les datas te disent il y a
999 chances sur 10000 kitch
et peut-être que une fois sur 10000 on
se trompera mais on se dit ok ça vaut le
ça vaut le coup ou pas on dit non il y a
quand même une chance sur 10000
bah non mais en fait à part faire
confiance au data
je vois pas de cas où tu puisses faire
un truc systématique ou quoi et tu vas
pas toujours trouvé quelqu'un ils sont
son apparition lui en plus pour fuyer
quelqu'un faut quand même le droit de le
faire normalement faut être sincèrement
quoi c'est pas un arbitre cyclisme il y
a carrément des des perquisitions hein
non mais
okquisition les mecs rendent chez toi
ils perquisitionnent ton appartement
donc on pourrait faire des perquisitions
après faudrait une autre clairement une
autre politique enfin mais on pourrait
imaginer des perquisitions chez des gens
enfin genre c'est quand même du vol
après au bout d'un moment donc mais je
veux dire moi je ferai carrément en fait
moi je mettrais bien de la police
c'est-à-dire si les datas sont comme ça
que ça puisse permettre à la police
d'aller faire des perquisitions lire les
mails des gens et faire une vraie
enquête là tu trouves des preuves quand
tu vas commencer chez les gens fouiller
tu peux trouver des choses a priori les
machins
et pas que Amazon là tu peux quand tu
mets une seule solution évidemment mais
voilà mais comme dans tout mais là en
fait pour l'instant on a eu beaucoup
trop on est fleurs bleues quoi en plus
quand il y a des styles qui sortent tout
le long
après il y a des listes avec des
connaît on sait qu'il y a eu des
problèmes après tout le monde s'en fout
on le voit donc ça sent sur les chats ou
quoi mais
mais oui nous on sait en fait donc c'est
c'est sûr que
et donc tu as des joueurs qui
réussissent en faire abstraction et
d'autres non
et nous côtés français c'est vrai qu'on
a des joueurs qui ont du mal en
généralement à faire abstraction
d'ailleurs il y a eu quasiment aucun
Français à l'IRISA est le seul français
je crois qu'il y a participé aux
qualificats
oui les autres pays étaient beaucoup
plus représentés ouais
donc
du coup la partie s'animer
c'est à dire que il y a ici c'est d'y
aller j'ai bouffé le pion à 5
et
il a bien blindécis à la place mais on
voit qu'il est paralysé quoi qu'il y a 5
peut pas quitter sa case parce qu'il y a
plus raciste derrière la tombée 5 a du
mal à bouger parce qu'il y a aussi assis
et donc une sorte de supériorité
numérique elle est le roi pour les
blancs avec une pièce en plus qui joue
et pour l'instant il mène bien sa barque
Wesley
bateau
parce qu'il est pas bien après
mais ouais tu peux tu peux enfin voilà
c'est c'est une évolution qui va devoir
avoir lieu et je
c'est pas que je suppose c'est que je
sais qu'il y a des joueurs qui
réussissent pas à performer si vous
posez des questions
parce que parce que parce que un peu la
parano bah il y a aussi ne pomyachi qui
a dit lui-même qu'il avait déjà triché
sur internet donc c'est il y a des
joueurs du top niveau top Topsy c'est
numéro 2 mondial c'est quand même pas
n'importe quoi il a dit lui-même qu'il a
triché il y a pas si longtemps que ça
sur internet mais parce que on discute
mais je la comprends en fait
non mais je suis d'accord
triché donc il a triché
moi aussi je mets l'ordi pour voir il
perdait quand même donc là il était sûr
que le mec mais tu as quand même des
doutes dans ces cas-là c'est l'inception
de la triche c'est que comme tu dois
douter d'à peu près tout le monde et
c'est normal
tout le temps et puis et puis ça va tout
le temps si tu gagnes tu dis oui bon bah
de toute façon je suis plus fort c'est
normal et puis si tu pertes c'est bien
la preuve de toute façon c'est une
attitude de quelqu'un qui triche
régulièrement de faire ça c'est
quand on arrive à allumer un deuxième
ordi pour vérifier le style maîtriche
c'est que c'est que tu le fais quand
même assez régulièrement c'est une
attitude de tricheur
en fait
mais
parce que toi par exemple tu le ferais
pas tu penses que le mec riche tu fais
comme moi tu signales puis tu joues tape
sur la table je m'insulte mais bon c'est
tout quoi
mais c'est lié à la parano dont on vous
parlait avant c'est pour ça que je me
permettais ce petit rebondissement c'est
que c'est dans le fond c'est pas
quelqu'un qui triche mais en fait ça le
saoule tellement de penser que tous les
autres triches que du coup tu deviens
fou et tu commences à te faire aussi un
truc qui vit dans le vélo quoi
et puis là en fait il te défonce tous
quoi et tu sais très bien pourquoi
aussi j'en ai marre
qui par ricochet en fait il triché pas
tout d'un coup tu t'es mis à le battre
et du coup en fait
et c'est un peu le cercle vicieux
attendez vite c'est bien joué il y a pas
tout reprend des 8 à cause de dame prend
et c'est le cavalier à 5 qui emprise
c'est obligé il l'a et là c'est pas mal
j'aime bien sa position mais bon
s'accroche à dur et dur ça peut être sûr
mais il a pas encore imposé
non pas encore
moi j'appelle ça l'inception de la
triche en fait c'est un truc qui s'auto
alimente tout le monde pense que tout le
monde triche
et il y en a d'autre enfin voilà quoi
c'est l'inception non mais c'est pour ça
que chaque fois très sévère parce que à
un moment tu vois ce que ça te coûte et
ça peut être passé l'envie
parce que pour l'instant ça qui a pas
vraiment de suspension enfin c'est léger
pour le moment il y a rien
je vais pas dire que c'est encouragé
parce que c'est pas le cas mais non mais
limite enfin oui
c'est pas très dur mais le truc c'est
comme il y a beaucoup de choses qui
peuvent gagner
faut tomber sur le bon en fait sur le
bon numéro
c'était bloqué le C2 il peut sauter
c'est pour ça que je dis c'est le truc
clean en fait mais
il a pas il va jouer avec le pion de
plus mais c'est dur d'avancer
c'était pas facile parce qu'il y avait
trop de variantes qui donnaient avantage
c'est jamais simple quand il y en a
qu'une oui bah tu tombes dessus
bon après ça il peut la gagner enfin
j'en sais rien mais il y a quand même de
bonne chance
dans son livre que les positions les
plus difficiles ou c'est
plus difficile à défendre c'est quand tu
as mal enfin perdant perdant perdant
perdant perdant et mal tiré tiens et en
fait ça cinq variantes tu as le choix tu
en as quatre qui perds et tu en as une
c'est mal mais ça tient ça c'est très
dur
parce que si c'est les trucs forcés en
ligne tu trouves tout en fait
5 normalement
bon là ça prend forme
[Musique]
en fait quand il y avait des tours on
était pas si c'était chiant là d'un coup
le roi court on est on est tranquille
quoi
pas fait encore quand même non bah oui
tu peux trouver une fourchette mais là
la position est vraiment gagnante et tu
as pu
du tout
d'attention il faut prendre ces trois ce
serait une gaffe
c'est n'importe quoi
qui capte le cabinet mais normalement tu
suces pas du tout envie de changer ses
options là quoi
en tout cas sur ce coup-là
c'est complexe
mais il a raté une fois il peut pas le
rater deux fois
avoir vu
donc il va tenter FK
pas encore fait
c'est peut-être pas gagnant ça
bah
faut être trop précis pour défendre je
pense aussi
mais bon ça a tellement de chaud que le
coup d'avant je m'y attendais tellement
pas
genre
je sais pas ça va ça va craquer ça c'est
pas possible ça tienne quoi
au moins ça peut tenir
je suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec
toi c'est avantage blanc mais je dirais
pas 100% quand même
tu peux te faire bloquer
parce qu'en fait comment tu vas passer à
une fois que tu vas
j'ai trois maintenant
il rate beaucoup de trucs qui sont pas
simples mais qui sont pas non plus
insurmontables pas très dur quand même
mais je crois que
c'est dur les échecs
si stress c'est dur
il commence quand même à s'organiser de
mieux en mieux il a repris 21 secondes
je suis pas sûr qu'il soit bien
repartir
va pouvoir mettre le pion H6
ça panique
OK
5 rois G8 3G 6 il a réussi non sans
effort
mais là il y a plus de coup
peut-être un cavalier F6 dernière
tentative
toutes les prises marche ouais mais bon
tu
tu fais peur
ça fait rire
donc ça fait Punto pour Wesley écoute
belle victoire très très maîtrisé comme
parti voilà il a raté un truc à un
moment ou un autre mais dans le bonne
partie ouais
mais il a quand même été assez facile il
a dominer de A à Z donc femme on va se
lancer pour une petite pause OK et on
revient dans une dizaine de minutes
à tout de suite
[Musique]
les amis ça a repris plus vite que prévu
ça reprit plus vite que prévu on s'est
fait dribbler
on s'est fait dribbler mais c'est pas
grave on est allé se faire un thé on
discute un peu des parties
et on discute un peu du tournoi avec
femme en off on se fait virer la lumière
il va revenir mais bon après on a raté
quelques coups mais ils sont passés vite
aussi
ouais bah écoute il attaque avec les
Noirs absolument rien à
c'est quoi cette
mais il s'est chauffé
bon c'est vrai
la partie
pourquoi pas pour casser ce clouage
ils ont dit qu'ils ont mis sur la chaîne
principale j'ai pas trouvé la technique
en finale moi très
ouais non mais pourquoi pas on s'en fout
en fait pourquoi pas en fait
il a gagné la finale en tout cas
après ils sont très heureux d'envoyer
toujours des superlatifs meilleurs
joueurs de finale de l'univers je
rappelle Wesley sceaux
[Musique]
pourquoi pas
Cristiano Ronaldo en fait
je joue au foot avec lui dans
2014 et tu avais sentiments
je sais pas en fait
je reviens dans un an ou deux en Europe
je sais pas ce qu'il veut en fait
c'est un délire
je sais pas en fait
OK
ni la façon gagné la finale ouais enfin
c'est passé par une phase où elle était
nul quand même
ouais non mais bon on échange des tours
c'était pas une super idée puis après il
faut faire une cavalier il aurait pas dû
il n'a pas pris du premier coup ouais
c'était mais bon après ils avaient peu
de temps ils ont pas trop de temps
qu'il connaît
bah ça se peut en fait bon faut que j'ai
5 tu farces un peu les HTC G5 donc ça
peut étonnant qu'ils connaissent ce qui
se passe là
mais je sais pas si on est obligé de
faire ça c'est pas trop mon répertoire
donc je peux pas trop vous dire
mais du coup quand tu dois juste pour
faire du les noirs
c'est pas la position de rêve quoi très
près ta petite finale de la berlinoise
ouais je sais pas il a décidé de rentrer
dans un truc un peu particulier ouais
c'est
il est chaud
S
[Musique]
il est mieux c'est plus rigat ici c'est
Riga ici les gays les frérot il est
heureux
[Musique]
on dirait un peu on dirait un peu
Jacouille quoi
c'est magnifique en fait je crois que tu
prends une longue focale et tu fais un
zoom ou un truc comme ça pour faire ces
plans là c'est un truc pour filmer le
loin mais du coup
[Musique]
en tout cas il clique vite
j'adore la scène dans les visiteurs
Jacquouille il est à terre au repas
[Musique]
ils sont très heureux quoi
tellement il est meilleur scène du
cinéma français en fait exceptionnel
mais c'est bizarre ils sont pas arrivés
à refaire bien après les suites
c'était vraiment
c'était du génie en fait oui mais enfin
tu vois j'étais allé voir quand ils ont
fait les visiteurs le dernier il y a
quoi il y a trois quatre cinq ans
c'était pas très drôle tu allais j'ai
pas critiquer en fait ça fait toujours
plaisir voir les personnages ou quoi
mais ça rien à voir avec le niveau du
premier ah mais le premier je me pose la
question c'est est-ce que parce qu'on a
déjà trop vu le truc on s'y attendait le
premier en fait du coup ça aurait été le
3 enfin celui qui est là qui sera sorti
il y a 20 ans on aurait quand même
trouvé ça génial aussi à l'époque ou pas
je sais pas
mais toujours est-il oui excellent film
le 2 est pas mal quand même aussi mais
moi en fait ça et tu as vu
ils sont aux États-Unis
[Musique]
la révolution à l'époque la révolution
je l'ai pas vu mais il paraît qu'il est
cata
mais je sais pas pourquoi en fait pour
le
couper un peu les
de différence enfin en fait tu viens du
Moyen-Âge à Manon tu comprends plus rien
à la Révolution ça reste
quoi mais sinon il se baladent en
calèche en cheval enfin tu as pas un
énorme décalage temporel quoi
donc il y a peut-être de ça aussi qui
joue je sais pas
c'est marrant aussi quand
[Musique]
je suis fier de toi
tu peux pas prendre le cavalier
avec le cavalier
non mais le 2 il était quand même
ça va passer quand même
déjà tu as les autres qui sont trompés
qui sont lancés un temps ah mais oui oui
et puis il y a plus le merci c'était en
plus
en fait elle jouait bien vraiment très
bien mais en fait va y remercier elle
était tellement c'était bien pour ce
rôle là
du coup en fait c'est plus elle souffre
plus la comparaison que le fait qu'elle
joue
tellement bien
et tout dans l'intonation ouille voyons
en réalité si ça arrivait on pourrait
pas communiquer avec eux
tu comprends pas un mot en fait
on comprendrait deux trois mots mais on
pourrait pas communiquer en fait
ils ont ils ont fait parler comme mon
imagine qui parle comme il parle
vraiment
comme ça en fait pas du tout enfin ça
aurait aucun rapport
et je pense que si je sais pas comment
ça se passe si tu as quelqu'un en
imaginant qui parle comme toi qui est
arrivé
dans le futur évidemment enfin
à quel niveau ouais je sais pas bah non
mais évidemment que tu comprends rien
mais genre à quelle vitesse tu pourras
un peu t'adapter essayer de te battre je
pense même déjà de 50 ans c'est une
grosse différence
[Musique]
et donc pour essayer de comprendre ce
qui se passe les noms mais ils ont la
paire de fond en échange et un potentiel
d'attaque va le voir blanc quoi
voilà
grosso modo
il suffit de voir comment parler nos
grands-parents dans les archives ouais
mais bon tu les comprends oui
c'est plus l'inverse qui est compliqué
allume la mèche
ou des expressions un peu de patois mais
ça va c'est pas c'était pas fou le pas à
toi non plus quoi ce qu'ils disent nos
arrières grands-parents ça peut être
plus compliqué mais j'ai pas connu
[Musique]
on organise
très beau de sortir la bande organisée
en 1960
je pense qu'ils sont pas bien non
personne ne peut canaliser voilà ça va
marcher de ouf
et c'est très novateur c'est magnifique
une phrase en 1950 wesh alors ma race
tranquille quoi
je pense les gens ils débloquent non
c'est ton temps c'est tranquille ou quoi
on aura 2 secondes 3 enfin bon quand
même hein
tu dois pas être bien
tu dois vraiment pas être bien
960 tu entends ça tu dois
il fait nul direct
tu reprends et
j'en sais rien en fait
[Musique]
c'est compliqué comme partie
à deux après tu feras B3 à 4 et
tu échange tout ça devrait faire nul
mais c'est un peu le situation inverse
la partie d'avant quoi
en 1960 il y avait pas de carte bleue
encore c'est arrivé quand les cartes
bleues
plus ou moins par là mais ça c'était la
carte de crédit au début
tu te mets un crédit après et il y avait
pas les codes tu devais passer là ça
faisait un peu bicarbones et tu les
signer
c'était la mec je pense au début et
c'est là qu'il y avait le film avec les
faussaires là comment il s'appelait
Caprio
est passé ta carte en fait ouais bah
fallait peut-être rosé peut-être qu'il y
avait des sortes de vérification mais et
on se trouve tu vois dans 50 ans on
parlera de maintenant on peut tout
vaquer facile je sais pas si tu es con
enfin tu vois peut-être c'est pareil je
sais pas
et
donc
je crois que c'est ça le coup il y a
dame prend le 3 parce qu'il est en train
de danser
4 et 6
c'est terminé
tu peux peut-être tenter qui aille H5
dame prend tu reprends D1 j'ai trois
tu vas te faire mater autour des 8 ah tu
es obligé en fait de tenter ça
mais bon ça va pas aller ouais c'est
c'est gagné
donc on va avoir WC on va nous dire dans
combien de temps
j'ai chopé l'info
beau match en attendant tranquille
rien à faire en fait c'est vraiment
obligé de faire tourner un sinon tu
perds après bon ton père mais il n'y a
rien à faire
parce que ça perd enfin le match quoi
en fait c'était pas simple mais tu es
compliqué on disait trop rien parce que
genre ça fait rien puis on a des
discussions intéressantes sur la
visiteurs et
et Zumba café mais
il a bien géré parce qu'il descendu à 5
minutes sur la pendule contre quasiment
15 donc il se prend tous les coups au
début il a su réagir elle a trouvé du
coup avec précision donc bravo et ça
nous fait du coup
a clairement les trois meilleurs joueurs
à la fin on a
ce qu'on disait en début de stream
c'est les 3 meilleurs après de temps en
temps ça peut ne pas passer mais
le même logiciel que nous
ils peuvent
alors du coup ça reprend 19h je suis en
train de choper l'info d'accord on
attend une réponse
ce serait logique de laisser comme une
petite pause
c'est prévu à 18h45 là c'est logique
quand même de lui laisser enfin tu vois
si il a il finit en magasin
si tu gagnes vite bon tu as un petit une
petite pause
et donc voilà pour ceux qui arrivent au
plateau repas en plus femme j'ai acheté
j'ai acheté de la plancha
j'ai acheté du jambon cuit au romarin et
du fromage de tête
et du fromage de brebis des Pyrénées
un petit café avec Sofia
tu as pris un deux personnes deux
personnes
[Musique]
[Rires]
forcément il a pas le choix mais c'est
terminé
mais là il doit y avoir plus d'une
manière d'y arriver
ça défend la cage j'évite il a fait
dommage de
ouais c'est ce que j'allais dire
descend la tour Tanger moi c'est ce que
je pensais ouais
pas prendre 4 par contre
même pas voulu
donc demain déjà on est sûr d'avoir un
beau match puisque on aura soit 45 so
soit Carlson dans tous les cas ce sera
une belle affiche
un petit peu la jouer quand même il y a
ici
quand même
si vous faitez 7 mais bon il y aura un
perpète probablement
ok pourquoi il a pas fait tourner deux
quand même par principe non mais c'est
terminé pour ce match on va attendre je
vais attendre l'info pour savoir à
quelle heure ça prend avant de faire la
pause
en tout cas un très beau match hein
j'attends d'avoir la réponse
bon c'est pas pour le moment donc on va
faire une pause et puis on reviendra
vous dire quand on sera
mais j'imagine
une petite pause puis on revient quand
on sait on donne l'info 45 ouais à mon
avis ça va être 45 mais bon une fois
qu'on sait on reviendra allez à tout de
suite alors faites on fait un petit on
fait un petit aller-retour
à tout de suite
[Musique]
et voilà les amis ça va repartir
les noms tout ça mais
on va le faire
00 ça c'est fait joueur Cam 2 il est là
du coup il faut qu'on change les noms
donc c'est saut en haut maintenant qui
va peut-être être dominé cette fois-ci
et plus dominant entre la caméra
on va te prendre un cas
et
du coup vas-y on va les mettre qu'on
suit le joueur
la finale des loosers mais du coup pas
vraiment looser
et il faut qu'on change c'est pas parti
mais c'est pas grave alors c'est une
italienne
je crois que c'est qu'ils ont joué ça
tout leur premier match en fait qu'on
avait pas suivi pour le coup regarder
Magnus
B5 et puis on prend puis on prend il
faut prendre ah ça marche pas faut
prendre je vais essayer de mais elle
souffre français si ça à la fin
tu prends bien
peut-être ça passe
mais ça j'ai déjà
une mauvaise idée de donner deux pièces
pour la tour pas toujours c'est souvent
une nouvelle idée neuf enfin les prisons
F2 c'est plus que 9 fois sur 10 non mais
en rêve ça a l'air complètement pourri
mais pas en l'autre jour quand tu
comptes avec Mathieu il bouffé des 6
ouais mais il avait pris deux pions il
avait pris deux pions et c'est déjà une
autre histoire mais globalement en fait
la règle à retenir
c'est pas que tu es longue torption
c'est moins fort que deux pièces c'est
que en fait au moins en début de partie
les tours jouent mal on va la tour à 8
elle est pourrie la torréfut était le
fait rien la tour 1 bon elle fait pas
grand chose par contre plus la partie
avance plus il y a peut-être des
échanges et la tour commence à avoir son
vrai potentiel avec des colonnes qui
s'ouvrent et cetera mais là on est
plutôt début de partie et donc deux
pièces légère vont clairement dominer
depuis plus plus utile quoi
clairement en gros c'est ça la règle de
fond
peut-être que le même sacrifice dans 40
coups contre un peu dans une finale ça
crée un pion passé qu'on va d'un côté et
la tourelle qu'on s'attractive elle va
peut-être même dominer les pièces mais
ça serait une autre histoire
complexe mais du coup je sais pas je
suis pas bien aimé son aller-retour en
G4 moi non plus si t'as pas surtout avec
trois chute c'est pour pas faire F5 non
mais en général au pire c'est pour faire
quel H6 alors
le cavalier
juste fait prendre un peut être ouais
mais ça arrive enfin
je veux dire mais j'ai déjà vu des alpha
zéro quoi faire en fait
en tout cas lui il a décidé de pas le
faire mais du coup bon clairement c'est
pas terrible
elle pourra se doubler quelque part
le match là et du coup tu vas pas en
finale de winner
c'est la vie hein
[Musique]
donc c'est la particularité de ce format
les deux joueurs sont affrontés en
demi-finale il y a deux jours
c'est imposé mais non sans malin il y
avait eu quatre parties nulles
Armageddon cinquième nul mais il avait
les Noirs un peu ce qu'il y avait
derrière et donc il est mis avec 5
minutes
c'est qualifié et
d'affilée
mais bon ça arrive genre c'est un peu le
même principe que sur tennis tu perds 7
6 6 7 7 6 j'ai jamais fait braquer mais
tu as perdu quoi
pelka voilà un truc comme ça
Opel cas ça fait un moment qu'on l'a
plus sur le circuit d'ailleurs et il y a
un problème de connexion peut-être pour
Wesley attention
aujourd'hui et bien évidemment demain à
ne pas rater sous aucun prétexte la
grande finale
18h17h pardon
17h 21h improbablement à peu près un peu
moins mais vraiment à ne rater sous
aucun prétexte to right under no
protectes
qui est un faux amis
et qui veut dire une jolie femme une
nounours
[Musique]
le verbe to right
ING tu vois
donc ouais demain grande finale donc ce
sera venu c'est un qui attend le
vainqueur de ce match là alors le final
qui pourrait dans un cas de figure
s'éterniser c'est si l'adversaire de
Magnus venait battre parce que là ta
Magnus bon Camille n'a pas perdu la
devis
donc on demande pour avoir clairement
huit articles
au maximum on aurait huit parties quatre
parties en Armageddon de partir en
Armageddon ça pourrait être un bo une
fois
qu'il y a de l'autre ah ce serait beau
ce serait beau Fabien très clairement
si en finale et bah du coup comme on
disait c'est Magnus qui attend le garde
ce match donc là on peut donner un
finaliste mais pas encore le second
Garden j'ai plus assez de force donc
probablement demain je resserre un peu
avant la finale de Blitz et probablement
lundi on se retrouvera pour de la
pédagogie mais j'ai besoin de repos un
petit peu
mais là tu streames plutôt en début
enfin avant ça quoi vers 16h vers par là
quoi ouais pour un petit peu quand même
en quoi cela se met en place il attaque
F7
et il a deux tempos d'avance en fait
j'ai réfléchis ils ont fait en fait le
même placement sauf que en G4 et revenu
pour
il y a vraiment perdu de thèmes pour
mais bon c'est pas si grave
mais c'est pas tu as pas perdu pour
autant mais
j'aimerais bien avoir si j'avais deux
coups en plus tu avais une dame en 7 à
fond aussi bon tu préférerais quand même
je préfère que d'être là
perte de temps c'est ça abandon
7 tu es touché par kf5 là avant
tu es plus serein et donc on va voir
comment ça va tenter de profiter de tout
ça
c'est même pas sûr je puisse en profiter
vraiment enfin j'ai pas de couilles
mais en fait le problème c'est que si
juste
ah si Sao crée pas de problème je dis
pas de gagner parce que bon c'est dur de
batnaka quoi qu'il en soit quel que soit
la position mais si il arrive pas à être
mieux je sais pas faudra être jolie quoi
si on peut te faire
quand même
donc on va voir à Wesley mais là faut
trouver une idée
il va finir son développement et a
proposé l'échange des fous de caisse
blanche en cas d'échange il est content
il va se doubler les pions mais ça va
renforcer son contrôle central et ouvrir
la colonne 9
aujourd'hui changement de la puissance
Starbucks
faut arrêter l'italienne pour Wesley non
mais c'est pas facile ces positions de
prendre l'avantage de faire la
différence
dans un truc qu'on voit tout le temps
donc
rien quoi
je sais pas quoi dire
qu'il faut que je joue au calme
et c'est une belle écossaise avec
une vidéo qu'on pourrait faire on a
failli faire avec Mathieu bon il avait
rien obtenu c'était quand même fait un
c'était une belle partie
soit bien défendu mais tu sens que tu
étais à une erreur de me battre
c'est genre de position d'écossaise ou
c'est hyper ouvert où les blancs
initiatives soit tu trouves et tu
liquide ça tu trouves pas et tes matins
bravo à lui mais
ça me rappelle une partie de Thomas chef
qui contenait pas
trouvé il a abandonné en 23 coups
de théorie en partie trois coups
après bon bah
attends
il a travaillé comme un fou
il a faim
non mais ils jouent bien quand même
enfin c'est pas mauvais joueur était
déjà 25 30 à l'époque c'était vraiment
beaucoup non mais c'est un bon genre il
l'appelle le professeur et mais en tout
cas son répertoire c'est c'est nickel il
connais Céline sur le bout des doigts
c'est maîtrisé ou quoi mais
qui s'appelle le Botanic le Botanique
c'était un peu comme les gamins à
l'école c'est les intellos mais
intello un peu marcher dessus
un peu une merde
tu as un con quand même
le prof t'adore en fait tu es une merde
quoi en fait
j'adore le mot botanique
nous sommes un magasin chez nous
Botanic c'est un rapport avec les
princes tout ce qui est en rapport avec
les arbres les plantes quoi
j'ai un peu j'ai un peu connu mais tu
sais qu'il se rappeler la partie qui a
joué contre moi très important
j'avais vu une fois j'étais un dîner
avec
ses servite clôture dans ton affaire
mais où il y a tous les meilleurs mais
du cramé il y avait tout le monde et
j'étais retrouvé invité à la céramique
clôture je trouvais une table avec les
cons vous voyez les petits mots
fléchettes
un peu les cons tu vois partie
en fait tous les coups tu vois ça
c'était que 27 25
et moi il y a eu vladocif ça rend la
table de la deuxième division
parce que j'ai l'impression de plus
machin ça a duré 6h à me battre du coup
après ta team moi aussi on a joué une
partie
[Musique]
il est vraiment pas mauvais ouais je
pense il y a combien ici à l'autre table
du coup ce qui était encore fort à
l'époque moi il est peut-être inarquée
mais ouais
donc tout ça pour dire quoi tout ça
c'était gros joueur mais juste en
dessous et j'avais fait une très belle
vidéo d'ailleurs de sa défaite contre
carne
de voir et de revoir
ça fait penser
à quel genre espagnol un jardin quoi
juste tu arrives jamais quoi et pourtant
tu es très fort et
ce sont des
on peut pas faire mieux
mais ouais du coup
ouais
un peu pareil je préfère yak en fait je
pense qu'il est plus fort mais pas de
beaucoup
et pas de même profil mais en fait en
gros c'est quelqu'un qui pourra pas
faire enfin c'est fini maintenant mais
il pouvait pas faire plus que ce qu'il a
fait quoi c'était très beau joueur
c'est toujours pas la parole bah en fait
il n'est pas sur ma table mais je pense
c'était de la sur la table sur laquelle
il a dressé la parole aux gens
[Musique]
j'avais quand même envoyé une très
grosse punch à qui après le truc de ce
village j'avais envoyé une énorme punch
juste elle était tellement grande que je
peux pas la dire en live
j'allais dire un truc très méchant mais
quand il est parti
mais j'aurais dit s'il avait été là en
fait ce que j'ai pensé à la punch après
une fois
il y a un truc très très méchant
qui avait fait rire tout le monde
d'ailleurs
[Rires]
tout le monde était très heureux mort de
rire oui très bien parler
votre santé
[Rires]
en 97
il aurait pu faire une carrière plus
grosse
très bon en calcul
er très bien et non mais oui
impressionné alors j'ai jamais joué mais
j'avais joué contre le Nao cheese club
il jouait Paul Nao à l'époque et je
compte le tien je sais pas nous on
analyse quand c'est fini j'ai perdu j'ai
fait nul mais bon et
mais juste avant on suit il doit voir
conçu il vient il te dit un coup il se
revarent en fait en plus un coup
complètement enfin
je sais plus d'un coup qui est très fort
profil actif enfin qui fait vraiment
chier quoi dans la position et bon
bah que moi je l'ai pas la regarde mais
genre lotier déjà c'était c'était fort
et en fait vide-leur tu vois juste en
tournant dans la salle et sans regarder
[Musique]
instantanément
j'ai compris que après il a eu toujours
beaucoup de mal contre MZ par exemple
s'ils ont le un peu le même profil un
peu moins vite il va un peu moins vite
quand même mais
après c'est pas la génération enfin
match je sais pas mais c'est vrai que
ouais il suit à chaque fois qu'on me
Maxime
ISU qui dépasse du tout alors qu'il
était plus fort que ce vide là
mais c'est un super pote et on a fait
plein de soir ensemble on a toujours
énormément rigolé avec Sacha et
Sacha lui laisse avec les gens qui
jouent aux échecs
j'espère que moi en fait pour lui je
suis dans l'échec pour lui donc ça va
donc ça va en fait il est avec les mecs
à 2005 machin genre oui mon mais enfin
disons que si tu fais le malin parce que
tu veux devenir grand maître ou quoi
non il va te prendre pour une merde très
clairement ah oui il me tient lui il
essaie de passer grand maître il est
vraiment nul mais si tu es normal tu oui
bon moi j'ai arrêté les échecs je suis
nul enfin il est enfin il est il a
compris oui bravo enfin tu es très
intelligent bravo machin en fait il est
snob avec les gens qui se croient fort
aux échecs
mais si tu te prends pas la tête à te
croire aux échecs il est très sympa même
si tu joues genre moi qui joue encore
[Rires]
mais si tu te prends pas la tête et que
tu es non enfin tu fais pas trop d'échec
machin et tout il te considère pas dans
le joueur de chez eux au contraire très
doué lui
c'est pas trop ça
pour te dire
ça aurait été beau ça tourne
mais bon c'est aussi peut-être du fait
que les carreau a fait son aller-retour
et que du coup il y a quand même une
petite pression avec les Blancs on voit
il y a les mêmes pièces mais les blancs
avancer au centre ils ont pu en D4 c'est
toujours mieux que des 6 donc ils
pourront choisir quoi faire donc rien on
prend pousser enfin débile dans ce cas
précis mais
il verront bien sûr il va faire ils
peuvent faire peur voilà
et de deux si on décale il prend des
cases c'est-à-dire qu'il y a pas de
caisse 5 il y a pas de trucs comme ça
alors que qui est de lui peut venir en
C4 c'est déjà une grosse différence il
vient de tomber voilà mais il veut te
bouffer le fou il fait des choses
pour te faire mépriser par Grisha ouais
mais tu ferais mépriser par penser
en fait
[Rires]
mais après par contre il paraît qu'il
est très sympa celui-là
je le connais pas en fait je l'ai jamais
parlé
c'est lui qui m'a jamais parlé mais
je veux dire on n'a jamais eu l'occasion
même enfin il y a pas eu de
roi je me barre
et s'ouvrir la colonne C verset 7 donc
ça normalement bonne chance pour les
blancs alors après le fait parce que il
veut faire F5 il faut que le bordel mais
en soit c'est une mauvaise décision
juste en termes de structure par contre
si concrètement F5 ça lui permet de
faire des trucs ça c'est une autre
histoire
et d'ailleurs Hikaru
c'est un peu ce qui sait faire de très
bien c'est prendre des décisions
stratégiques
dans le monde n'a pas envie de faire
mais il arrive à la justifier
concrètement
on l'a déjà vu jouer avec des fous
pourri faire des trous et puis en fait
tu arrives pas à l'exploiter donc ça il
sait faire
et donc on va voir après bon soit je
veux dire les blancs restent mieux
mais il a compris il fait pas la
corneille
il est vraiment très fort un
je sais pas si va jouer la Coupe du
Monde ou s'il va jouer quelques
événements réels pour essayer de refaire
les candidats ou pas parce qu'il y a
plus Manu il peut même prétendre à
devenir champion du monde là qu'en
réalité
parce que franchement je vois pas moins
fort que
non non il est pas plus fort non plus
c'est pas n'importe quoi tu marques
l'histoire de ton sport tu es là pour
l'éternité quoi et ça doit être une
fierté donc c'est pas
déjà très peu de joueurs peut considérer
pour être champion du monde
donc quand tu es
dans cette caste entre guillemets d'élus
enfin que tu as ce niveau et que tu as
fait le travail pour que le talent pour
que tu as tout fait bah
je sais pas faut continuer à faire quoi
et peut-être pour rien mais tant pis au
moins tu auras pas de regrets à la fin
quoi en tout cas la Coupe du Monde il
pourrait essayer parce que juste son
style et ouais mais en fait bizarrement
il n'a jamais bien réussi la Coupe du
monde quand il a joué avant mais je sais
pas pourquoi enfin ça pourrait bien se
passer cette fois c'est pas une raison
mais c'est pas un tournant qu'il a
particulièrement bien réussi
je sais pas pourquoi
mais à sa place voilà on est conseil
ce qui va avoir le temps enfin ça
structure
et bouffer des
même si on pourra pas bouffer
je pense qu'on a un cas va quand même la
défendre
au moins enfin je veux dire ça va il
peut continuer à jouer les aliens il
arrive à faire quelque chose avec ces
temps de plus
quelque chose de probant après si ça
défend face ça défend face ça c'est une
autre histoire mais
a priori ouais
F2 tu veux planter
mais voilà et peut-être tu peux un peu
monter le roi un peu tes pions
[Musique]
peut-être qu'on retrouvera la Coupe du
Monde comme on le disait je l'espère en
tout cas parce que j'aimerais bien le
voir de nouveau candidats il était pas
loin déjà la dernière fois
c'est vrai que sans Magnus il peut
prétendre
peut gagner des candidats
non mais après c'est un peu la roulette
enfin c'est il peut ou pas
la dernière fois il a pas de chance que
Nico est encore écraser le temps
je sais pas combien mais il y a un
joueur qui était
pas de bol à la dernière de pas savoir
pourquoi il doit jouer machin et tout et
pas réussir à fermer parce que sinon
c'était neponaka non mais ça c'est
m'énerver
oui entendre mais je veux dire quoi
qu'il en soit il a dû savoir que
enfin tu dois le faire c'est à cause de
Magnus
il y en aura pas
c'est juste chauffer il a voulu
retoucher un peu l'échiquier un des
parties lentes et je les parties
compliqués pour juste réfléchir quitte à
jouer mal mais tant pis ça tourne dans
sa tête
ou alors juste non c'est qui il a du mal
ça fait longtemps parce que il a été
bloqué en Chine pendant longtemps et
Machin donc
donc je sais pas mais c'est une grosse
interrogation au niveau de Ding ça va en
soi que Ding Geneviève le champion du
monde je trouve ça normal il était
régulier numéro de mondial pendant
longtemps à plus de 2008 sauf que là
c'est peut-être justement le moment où
il doit plus l'être quoi parce que
peut-être qu'il vous moins bien que ce
qu'il a fait pendant 4 5 dernières
années
demande si elle est à peu gagner les
candidats et se qualifier oui il faut
juste qu'il se remette à jouer en fait
c'est tout après de base très favoris
quoi de base c'est quelqu'un qu'on voit
normalement à devenir champion du monde
enfin très clairement qu'il aurait la
carrure pour mais en fait si maintenant
il décide de plus vraiment jouer de plus
faire les efforts ce sera non
c'est clair donc ça après je sais pas ce
qu'il en tête s'il compte revenir
refaire les efforts et tout ça et il en
a le talent en tout cas voilà mais c'est
le même commentaire pour prendre un
carré quand je disais il devrait y aller
c'est quand ils sont rares ces gens là
et tu as envie de les voir faire le plus
possible mais après ça a des êtres
humains qui ont peut-être d'autres choix
d'autres ambitions d'autres priorités
j'en sais rien moi bref chacun fait ce
qu'il veut aussi et ce qui compte au
final c'est d'être heureux et qu'on
donne sa vie et
et après pas regretter dans quelques
années quoi
mais donc de prime abord il a le talent
et dans les jours actuels qui pourraient
faire des candidats bah oui donc tu as
normalement
bouger de toute façon
Tanaka bon Maxime c'est pareil j'ai pas
envie d'en mettre exactement mais il a
été top 5 mondial pendant longtemps
normalement il doit pouvoir y arriver et
après elle a eu un petit coup de mou
récemment ce qui va se remettre ou pas
c'est toujours du radire moi j'en sais
rien
et puis tu as les nouveaux qui poussent
et on verra à table ça t'auras et qui
tape à la porte
qui peut plus ou moins non sa
progression mais il est pas loin de
pouvoir prétendre jouer après
normalement c'est pas le tu as toujours
rappeur
et Douda là qu'on parle je les vois pas
venir je suis venu du monde mais
candidats d'ailleurs ils étaient la
dernière fois quoi donc ça c'est
complètement possible
je crois qu'il est en train de défendre
un aka
et on va voir il y a pas beaucoup de
temps on ne sait pas trop
mais oui je pense que effectivement ça
doit faire nul
parce qu'en fait le pion F2 est bloqué
en quelque sorte faudra arriver
quand tu te fais changer tu perds des 5
pour l'instant et de deux tout autant
donc pour tout ce qui sera perpète ou
pas par la suite plus simple
peut-être il devait pas échanger les
tours j'ai trouvé bizarre la décision
mais après
je pense pas non plus parce que les
reset elle a quand même gagné une grande
chaise tour l'an dernier
c'est pas une mince affaire c'est
difficile à dire non mais au fait en
gros mais bon c'est des sortes dynamique
c'est à dire que il y a un an de ça
quand il Rouja a gagné quasiment tout il
prenait des points une fusée bon tu dis
ça s'arrêtera jamais c'est bon il est
lancé et voilà et voilà c'est un peu ce
que fait nordique en ce moment mais bon
après jusqu'à quand jusqu'à enfin c'est
toujours dur d'être dans lecture de
l'instant quoi donc même à chaque fois
qu'il y a des jeunes qui font des
grosses performances on vous dit bon bah
potentiellement il peut être très fort
on sait pas nous enfin vous êtes
toujours dit on sait jamais enflammé sur
aucun jeune en fait
qu'il a envoyé à 28 28 quelque chose
il a passé la voiture ou 27,98 mais
qu'il a emmené au top 2 top 3 au top de
mondial et voilà donc écoute on verra on
verra mais de toute façon c'était la
question de Naka de base ouais moi
j'aimerais bien qu'il tente sa chance
s'il arrive pas tant pis alors j'espère
du 2 semaines de son temps c'est pas la
fin du monde
il sera temps d'ameçon 36e ouais ça sent
qu'il a laissé passer une occasion le G4
dame 6
un tournoi non plus hein
de vague il y a quand même plusieurs
résultats probants mais bon à lire-résa
c'était 8 sur 9 au championnat d'Europe
par équipe c'est vainqueur du Grand
Suisse vainqueur de la saison de grande
chaise tours 2022 c'est impressionnant
aussi c'est plus qu'on s'en leur dire
bec là hyper motivé hyper chaud et à
lireza dans une période creuse mais ça
veut pas dire qu'il y AESA ils disent
bon la saison elle reprend pour moi en
mai juin
je vais être en forme en mai juin
peut-être si je commence à monter en
forme en mai je vais être en forme en
juillet pour la Coupe du monde donc là
il est peut-être complètement dans une
période où il récupère il fait un peu
moins d'échec et il va se remettre à
fond
je sais pas moi partir d'avril je dis
une connerie j'en sais rien mais c'est
pas dit et peut-être que nos dir Beck il
aura été à fond pendant un an et demi et
il va arriver il sera un peu sur les
rotules et ça change vite les dynamiques
ça me fait penser au tennis des fois tu
as des gars ils gagnent les ATP 500 les
machins
[Musique]
qui était bien quoi
je sais pas
il a fait second mais il est en tête
pendant environ enfin 12 secondes
mais
donc
on verra en fait
c'est une première expérience si la Majo
au début il a bien fini c'est
comme dans tous les sports on monte au
Pinnacle les joueurs trop vite et on les
sent facilement non mais il y a trop
d'attente en fait
il a quand même un gros
trousigne s'est fait viser et maintenant
soit il réussit à fermer le trou et il
va être hyper fort soit il arrive pas
c'est déjà pas mal
mais pour le coup ouais pour revenir sur
Abdou je trouve pas qui qui joue trop
mais en fait il gère pas mal c'est ah il
joue mais tu vois on le voit pas jouer
tous les deux jours non plus et il a
raté un truc hyper facilement
avec 34 secondes d'un F3 c'est
enfin c'est fou ce que c'est ouais c'est
mille et l'eau quoi
à ce niveau c'est
mais je sais pas ce qu'il a fait ça fait
un moment qui
c'est déjà pas jouer à 4 ans ouais mais
bon
des exercices que le truc bon pour
montrer
non mais je viens de
c'est dommage c'était vraiment pas dur
quoi
incroyable
donc
incroyable ça c'est vraiment des ratés
en fait
c'était plusieurs que ça mais
pas beaucoup
en fait il voulait tellement faire nul
la deuxième partie qui pourrait être la
dernière
incroyable
c'est un trop gros
en gros tu es face au cash vide et tu
marques pas quoi ça peut arriver
d'autres occasions et marquer plus tard
mais
d'avoir une telle position de Naka ouais
ça fait tous les jours c'est vraiment
facile
c'est évident je sais pas comment dire
c'est pas leur niveau c'est un c'est
automatique c'est instantané c'est c'est
que tu sors peut-être un enfant de 8 ans
il fait même pas peut-être c'est
[Musique]
il va faire 8 ans c'est sûr mais bon
après tu peux
qui va comment dire tu peux toujours
te répéter dit ok bon ben c'est nul
c'est nul il a perdu l'ambition de
gagner bon ben j'ai raté ma chance ou je
sais pas ce qu'il se dit et tu as 30
secondes
et regarde même plus les coups mais
c'est
juste un petit piège
à gauche à droite quand tu dois gagner
le truc attends
attends je vais récupérer
en fait j'ai l'impression que quand tu
veux gagner ça
H4
AG ça doit pas gagner quand tu fais H4
il touche pas non mais en fait quand tu
auras faire 5 ok mais bon ça on va faire
un H4
et on va faire puis on prend f-p prend
et H5 passé et après on a le passage
il peut tromper il peut se tromper là en
fait ça fait pour nous c'est hyper
facile enfin hyper facile
on va faire
parce que bon vous avez compris que si
on fait ça on passe pas tiens les Noirs
ont passé leur vie à faire ça et on n'a
pas de passage le roi blanc ne peut pas
rentrer en position non nulle part ça
rien et il se passera rien donc mal
prise prise c'est chiant parce que le
pion il nous bloque un peu après je sais
pas si on a moyen de faire quelque chose
ou pas mais bon voilà et donc en fait ce
qu'on veut c'est garder un peu le statu
quo il se passerait il se passe rien on
fait ça et après quand on prend et qu'on
fait ça du coup c'est ce pion passé
c'est plus celui-là du coup le roi il va
rester dans cette zone et nous là du
coup on a un passage voilà donc c'est ça
qu'on disait et là ça va gagner
et même chose si vous demandez ah ouais
mais est-ce que le rail peut pas rester
par ici courir le passage bon déjà on va
venir et même si on triangule pas qu'on
est comme ça on fera H6 pour pour le
forcer à aller le prendre et rentrer un
moment mais sinon on peut juste tourner
et avoir la case d'entrée au bon moment
donc
mais ça pour un joueur amateur c'est pas
évident
ah ouais tu peux te planter quoi autant
le dernier froid je trouvais évident
autant le f43 F3 roi G3 je crois que tu
peux tu as plus de chance de se faire
mais bon normalement
[Musique]
ça c'est ce que on a regardé tout à
l'heure
il y a des chiens
regarder la pub sur la chaîne du Carouge
je suis hypnotisé
désolé
pour passer ce truc là
mais j'ai très envie qu'on aille voir ce
film c'est ouais mais ça a été
exceptionnel
[Musique]
alors pas du tout c'est fini
ça sera probablement NACA enfin vu le
raté mais bon après on sait jamais
bon au moins on a appris quelque chose
[Rires]
et du coup ouais qu'est-ce qu'on a pris
dans la finale était intéressante sur
visserie facile
je veux faire échange sur un compte
complètement de la merde c'est parti
c'est NACA
pendant le tournoi qui revient pas
directement
mal passé et c'est vrai conseil donc là
je je trotte pas c'est pas du troll mais
si tu as un truc qui s'est vraiment mal
passé comme ça que c'était trop mis la
pression c'est se branler
non mais je rigole pas du tout pour
repartir sur de meilleures bases mais je
te je te sais pas c'est pas du troll en
fait c'est non mais c'est des vrais
conseils de sport quoi
mais alors du coup c'est vraiment ça
stratégie c'est je mets les blancs à la
poubelle
ils sont fous du match hier
c'est cool je fais du spectacle sympa ça
me fait un Armageddon c'est cool
non mais bien sûr mais bon on aurait pu
avoir une partie là qui finissent quand
même par nul et avoir quand même l'armée
donc
où ça serait fini par un gain de l'un ou
l'autre il y en aura le spectacle
maintenant et quoi
ça le fait chier de jouer en fait
il est bien faire les armées
[Musique]
je reste on va dire mitigé sur ce
stratégie de jeter les blancs à la
poubelle
la théorie de Vlad quoi
il a pas eu le temps
non mais après c'est des vrais trucs de
sport enfin tu vois c'est pas c'est pas
du troll c'est pas des blagues en fait
c'est vraiment des trucs qui te
permettent de
t'attendais pas à moi de toute façon
quand tu as entendu là-dedans
ouais mais
tu es aussi là sur les bons conseils
quoi
d'ailleurs LeBron James il a fait le
nouveau record là oui
c'est pas
c'est pas vrai conseil en fait c'est
vraiment vraiment
je sais pas à quoi les gens réagissent
qu'il y a tellement de décalages entre
ce qui décrivent et qu'on dit qu'on peut
pas
mais bon on l'a vu
des centaines de fois maintenant
et du coup là ça prend bientôt c'est bon
il est content
et là de toute façon il peut pas faire
beaucoup mieux
quand tu te prends échec
tu mets ce fou tu vas te faire bouffer
celui-là donc ça va pas et si tu fais ça
alors je sais plus ce que c'est l'idée
des blancs mais peut-être juste de
clouer un peu tu vas pas rocker si
facilement et ou peut-être de t'envoyer
le cavalier tempo je sais pas mais en
tout cas enfin non aucune raison de
s'embêter mais même ça je viens ça doit
être suffisamment peut-être un coup
jouable
et donc en général ils font juste dame
là de toute façon les Blancs ont pas
envie d'échanger les dames je veux une
finale avec la paire de fou et le centre
ouvert bah ça c'est juste clairement mes
points noirs donc ils veulent pas ils
disent
parce que tu as envie de sortir ton fou
pour ok moi je te bouffe
et bah ils reviennent et puis bah vas-y
on l'entend quoi
donc voilà
la bienfait de pas partir parce que là
si on avait fait la pause on est arrivé
une minute en forme on avait
complètement raté
en fait
je suis très heureux de cette nuit
c'est rien merdychant
comme pour l'autre truc
en fait
non
mais juste je comprends pas la stratégie
de ne pas essayer de jouer un poil avec
les Blancs
il va être obligé de jouer je comprends
pas non plus ça me bute en fait
je suis dépassé en fait j'ai pas
d'explication à vous donner mais il fait
ça il a déjà fait ça hier et bon mais
dans ce qu'il fait c'est tout
oui c'est pas et bon
il clique et puis voilà je
n'ai rien à dire
mais bon au moins la prochaine partie
ça sera obligé de jouer jusqu'au bout
on a un peu de mal à le savoir
après on le voit sur Twitter en décalage
bah écoute n'a qu'à y arriver avec neuf
c'est vrai que ça dixième nulle de Naka
de suite
ça fait boum
je suis très arrêté d'un commentaire sur
youtube il y a un mec qui dit ouais ça
m'étonnerait qu'il écoute vraiment Yann
je suis allé écouter c'est vraiment de
la tour
qualifié
[Musique]
pas mal et ils vont se faire des
enchères moi j'ai mis 956 enfin 8 56
bien
une seconde de plus que moi
après vraiment le saint qui peut être
déçu de pas l'avoir fait
qu'est-ce que je voulais dire et on
demande si le délai fait exprès ouais
c'est fait exprès c'est pas de notre
fête c'est les ordinateurs du tournoi
qui ne veulent pas qui font un délai
comme il y a des délais en live
pour les tournois maintenant justement
pour combattre un peu la triche et donc
pour pas que les joueurs puissent suivre
le live ou qu'ils aient quelqu'un qui
suivent le live et qui puisse leur
communiquer les coups voilà
donc c'est ça l'idée après bon peut-être
d'autres moyens mais
en tout cas c'est ça l'idée qui est une
trente de décalage
donc ouais le truc bon c'est pas trop
grave vous voyez en live juste pas vrai
pour discuter avec vous et interagir
avec le chat c'est moi pratique un que
d'habitude
celle des fois on va dire mais bon c'est
comme ça vaut mieux ça que de la triche
oui
les joueurs sont là les joueurs sont
prêts les gladiateurs sont là face à
face ça va être sympa
là je suis très heureux de la petite nul
quand même
j'arrive pas à comprendre la cave avec
les Blancs
c'est très heureux aussi je sais pas il
se marrer ils ont encore joué une
seconde près encore
il doit pas être bien
trop bizarre
c'est marrant du coup Maxime qui vient
de cette grande partie
juste au bon moment
il a eu le flair
mais je vais essayer de voir sur Twitter
en fait si j'ai l'info
il est mort de rire quoi ça
ce qui se passe enfin on comprend que
c'est un peu comme hier mais je veux
dire c'est quoi le buteur officiel pour
suivre ben je vais essayer de faire
comme live
24 peut-être
j'en sais rien
bon je sais pas ça
sont très heureux
oui mais bon
non
mais écoute
15 minutes
[Musique]
normalement
bah oui mais bon ok il faut des trois
peut-être que ça va j'en sais rien
c'est bizarre qu'il ait fait quand même
en plus il suit complètement je sais pas
et ceux qui bon
ça généralement je défonce
et des fois tu perds un pion mais c'est
de mettre toutes tes pièces par là-bas
mais c'est moins bon que la vraie
variante mais c'est pas complètement
mais sauf quand même fou des trois c'est
fin c'est bizarre de pas connaître un
peu quand même
en fait
je sais pas franchement je vais te dire
de plus en plus fous bah ouais mais là
Maxime enfin dommage on parle avec une
minute trente d'écart mais
quand même étonné du Fou des trois enfin
surtout si sur des 6 sur réfléchis
parce que là quand même normalement
c'est C4 et comme tu dis c'est qu'elle
va aller au 7 2 3
mais c'est hyper danger
et sinon même si tu prends des 6 ou 30
tu peux que je suis quand même gagner
l'option 6 avec faux 4 quoi
mais je sais pas enfin pour dire c'est
plus ou moins vaguement jouable genre je
sais qu'il va disait vite il avait fait
Goran
alors c'est quoi son prénom
Silvan peut-être je sais pas
c'est beau quoi
bon bref
toujours est-il déjà joué comme ça
moi je pense pas à l'écossaise surtout
quand tu as plus de temps c'est une
ouverture très complexe et la myésis
c'est vraiment pas évident à jouer avec
les Noirs moi je trouve que avec 15
minutes contre 8 c'est plutôt une bonne
décision bah surtout que cela il se l'ai
prise contre
il est à faire nul mais qu'on dit mais
il a dû lutter avec les Noirs ouais ok
je sais que la théorie ça va mais que
donc
[Musique]
c'est hyper fort
et Dame des 4 c'est hyper
[Musique]
il est condamné de façon
mais par contre ça peut aussi être juste
simple
les trois coups qu'on a regardé c'est le
moins bon
c'est étonnant
mais si on commence à réfléchir c'est
qu'on se dit bon est-ce que j'ai autre
chose
joue pas super bien dans ce match il est
un peu fatigué aussi parce que ça fait
trois jours de compétition avant
quand même un pion de plus mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a ici trois direct
tu le feras au pire tu prends du
cavalier ou tu peux faire et
pareil tu gères
qu'est-ce que c'est fort mais je suis
pas sûr que j'aurais pensé
mais cavaliers C3 ouais plus humain on
est d'accord
et là il est dans le dur parce que on le
répète Armageddon les noirs peuvent
faire nuls pour gagner il y a pas de
rajouter de temps et là il lui reste
plus que 5 minutes 5 30 mais ça commence
à être à rentrer dans les la zone
dangereuse
moi je considère que jusqu'à 4-5 minutes
tu as encore du temps mais à partir de 3
tu commences à quand même être dans
l'urgence quoi
le truc aussi il faut être capable de
changer de braquage si tu as eu
l'habitude de jouer avec 10 minutes 15
minutes machin et là tu as plus de temps
se faire une partie en 3 minutes en fait
bon on fait tous les jours quoi mais
d'avoir trois minutes quand on a eu 15
avant tout le temps c'est pas pareil
quoi
mais après ça il a quand même laissé
beaucoup d'activités
ça joue pas super bien non
partez d'autre
mais comme on disait ça s'explique par
la fatigue par
je pense qu'il faut à trois là non
pourquoi pas mais pourquoi les freins à
deux
et sinon tu peux peut-être faire F3
on peut aussi avoir cette option
S
complexe comme position
vous pouvez nous écrire 10000 fois dans
le chat c'est quoi cette caméra le
problème c'est que c'est Wesley qui a
cadré sa caméra comme ça donc on peut
rien y faire vous pourrez l'écrire mille
fois ça changera rien en fait c'est
c'est juste qu'il a mis sa caméra comme
ça et mis sa caméra comme ça c'est pas
enfin c'est pas grave quoi non mais oui
c'est dommage ça je le conçois mais
il s'est mis comme ça il s'est mis comme
ça
voilà il va faire B3 et il juge
et donc du coup est-ce qu'il peut
essayer ça
en fait
il peut être en train de calculer les
trucs comme ça bah tu es mieux que les
Blancs après bon
hyper beaucoup de temps sur ce coup je
crois juste qu'il est dans le dur
enfin physiquement quoi
mais ouais je dois dire c'est pas c'est
pas simple
donc après
une grosse différence c'est pas jouer à
la seconde quoi il a dit à 8h30 mais
c'est fou en fait ça va aussi cher les
noirs
du coup pourquoi le tournoi en 15
minutes aussi si en fait finalement ça
suffit d'avoir 5 minutes pour jouer
aussi bien
une demi-heure non mais en fait
concrètement il reste 5 minutes à Naka
il faut quand même gérer
alors
il ouvre son fossette pour alors attends
je crois qu'il y a un truc incroyable
sur grand rock dame prend à trois puis
on prend à trois fous prends à trois
rois B1 tour B8
roi B2 roi B1 x 3
et
des cinq grands rock il faut prendre à
trois
rois des deux et il faut prendre B2
pièces
c'est n'importe quoi
c'est extraordinaire comme coup
prend à trois c'est un génie en fait
c'est extraordinaire
tu penses qu'ils avaient tous les deux
cinq mais une fois qu'il a vu des seins
il a compris quoi
c'était dingue
mais ouais bon je sais pas c'était pas
bien joué contre quoi qu'il en soit sur
sacrifice de viande non ça c'est sûr
mais si les lilas me prend à trois c'est
extraordinaire
mais là c'est très bien joué un qui est
D1 machin et maintenant il va faire un
grand rock ouais tranquille là-bas il y
a plus le fou pour te prendre à trois et
puis la dame
et il faut des quatre il est beau des
erreurs qui paraissent un peu je sais
pas évidente mais peut-être parce qu'on
rate des trucs mais alors des fois il te
voit de ces trucs c'est hallucinant
pas envie de rester là-dedans
et là-dedans là c'est sûr tu étais dans
trop de problèmes
donc
là maintenant c'est une position un peu
bizarre de roc opposée ou tu es pas
obligé d'attaquer avec les Blancs
peut-être que tu veux juste mettre ta
tour en un et commencer à échanger les
pièces
on va voir
là tu prends de F non t'installes ton
fou hyper fort en D4 tu le bouffes plus
et tu défends et Tac c'est ma théorie tu
te rappelles de toute façon il va
revenir en deux quatre oui mais bon non
non
en fait l'idée de NACA c'est de la
finale c'est plus du tout attaquer je
pense pas qu'il puisse attaquer le roi
non mais je pense c'est quoi y gagnant
pour les en fait et les blancs veulent
jouer l'attaque 5 tresses contre 4 03 tu
as plus d'attaque avec les Blancs et tu
as un plan de plus donc même si ton une
finale tu ça va être pas si mal et tu
arrives 3G4 aussi pour ouvrir s'il y a
besoin enfin ça fait beaucoup de trucs
après Wesley bah faut
il y a plus de colonnes de merde
il va faire nul en fait parce que le
pion A4 il est hyper fort il bloque les
trois pions
il a tellement mal joué
il a tellement raté de choses oui mais
c'est ce qu'on disait c'est lesquels
ouvertes
bon je sais pas c'est pas encore fini
pourtant il va faire de la fin
prise en fait tu vas commencer à avoir
des droits
quand même et je sais pas et le
contredit noir il n'existant avec
donc en fait dans mes fins c'est pas
vraiment une option et du coup là tu
menaces B3 mais il va peut-être faire
dames F5 mais bon du coup tu vois enfin
il y a pas de tête drôle c'est peut-être
nul mais bon c'est un peu
il empêche de nouveau
la finale c'est pas grave et surtout que
tu as gagné un tempo
mais il faut cliquer vite et garder
un peu favorisé c'est pour ça quand on
parle des fois Naka champion du monde de
Blitz machin et tout et pourquoi un peu
moins fort en réel parce que la toute
petite différence qui fait à la souris a
vu que les niveaux sont tellement
resserrés elle est énorme en fait je
pense pas qu'il bouge plus vite les
pièces sur un échiquier c'est bien joué
la roi des deux trois B3 il joue très
bien mais juste comme tu dis il faut
qu'il réussisse à jouer plus vite à se
garder une petite avance au temps
parce qu'il peut en avoir besoin
pour
Ikaru
il va faire
B320
tu te mets dans un échec potentiel un
jour mais là tu dois cliquer B3 CB tu
dois prêt move il a raison
sinon le roi après tu pourras toujours
repartir et le cacher sur case noire
parce que maintenant si tu changes les
dames c'est sûr qu'elle est gagnante
tout à l'heure il y a peut-être des
scénarios il y en avait qui était quand
même nul là maintenant déjà
bon je sais pas
je sais pas ce qu'il fait la même
position en fait à jouer au con comme ça
mais après peut-être qu'il veut refaire
le truc de regagner un peu de temps de
refaire la manœuvre mais c'est hyper
étonnant
il veut ah il va en fait si c'est ce
qu'il fait c'est trop génial ouais en
fait il veut sécuriser son roi et
attaquer le roi d'Ikea roux
ce qui est assez malin en réalité parce
que tu vois il garde une nuit d'avance
et je pense qu'en fait il se dit que si
réussi à mettre pression en fait il joue
la pendule d'avance et peut-être il fera
le truc quand il y aura allez on va dire
une 25 contre 35 secondes ce que tu vois
là il augmente son avance à la pendule
petit à petit
ce que tu vois il y a enfin disons en
fait moi il faut que les blancs il faut
jouer la pendule enfin on te donne 7
minutes d'avance au début il faut quand
même t'en servir quoi
le principe du truc c'est pour ça oui il
a pris moins de temps ok au bout d'un
moment ça doit payer
bien fait pour ça gueule bah ouais mais
bon c'est bien joué mais il faut être
précis
et oui arnaque mais il a pas assez joué
pour gagner
alors là il s'est fait arnaquer
juste au pire moment quoi
ouais mais parce qu'il a trop joué
longtemps pas pour gagner
il a trop longtemps jouer
bon c'est pas encore enfin bon là c'est
sûr qu'en fait hikao est sorti
d'affaires objectivement mais bon il y a
grande plus trop de temps il y a chanson
de plus et on va voir mais il a en
pourri sa position bien comme il faut
avec les Blancs
[Musique]
c'est 3 mais bon tu as perdu G3
c'est un truc je sais pas moi
beaucoup de ratés
il a sorti la botte secrète pourtant
l'écossaise
mais maintenant c'est Hiko en fait qui
est bien
son pion c'est plus facile à avancer
incroyable
on aura de nouveau
Ikao contre Magnus j'ai du mal à très
très bien joué la fiche qu'on voulait de
toute façon
ouais mais bon vu ce qu'a fait Wesley tu
aurais pu dire bon voilà il aurait dû
gagner mais il eu aucun réalisme il a eu
aucun réalisme
je sais pas quoi dire c'est comme ça
quoi non mais il y a tout raté
il a tout raté les amis quand tu auras
trop
ça y est il danse et le roi vient en
décès il coupe les deux tours
il est heureux
mais ouais c'est ouais il dégoûte enfin
c'est
en fait j'ai pas moi qui ai pas fait
vivre
il a complètement oublié la dame rentrer
en deux ou quoi il a eu quand même
[Musique]
il a eu ça là ouais prends tu peux je
sais pas ce que tu veux parce qu'on a 5
tu vas plus avancer beaucoup mais bon
peut-être tu fais dames ici tu me rends
c'est ça il va essayer d'avancer tes
machins ensemble et on verra
a tué la pression en tout cas
tu t'ennuies plus tard après son idée de
faire en soi elle est pas mauvaise mais
ouais elle a réalisation
tu peux faire étranger
ou quoi mais
[Musique]
bon c'est pas grave c'est comme ça donc
et ça nous refera une la même finale que
la finale des Winners au final donc les
deux plus forts qui se retrouvent à
nouveau voilà on va essayer surtout le
dame F3 qui peut regretter qui était qui
était vraiment facile
parce que peut-être que a gagné il y en
a partout aussi enfin peu importe c'est
une autre histoire mais faut prendre les
points quand on veut les prendre
bon bah les amis merci à tous d'avoir
suivi on se retrouve demain 17h pour la
grande finale du ring master je passe
une petite page de pub et on se quittera
là dessus merci à tous au revoir et
deuxième truc